Nouvelle vidéo, donc nouveau T-shirt
et flemme de repasser, donc sèche-linge.
Et salut !
Il y a quelques semaines, *lumière* je vous ai proposé un nouveau concept
Faire une Alfa-Q
Je ne crois pas que ça a déjà été fait, mais peut être que je me trompe, je ne connais pas tout internet non plus
Le principe était que vous m'envoyiez vos questions par un google form, et que je gardes une seule question par lettre de l'alphabet
Donc une question qui commence par A, une par B etc.
Donc il y a ... Roulement de tambour invisible ... 26 questions exactement.
J'ai donc tout envoyé à une amie chanteuse qui s'appelle Carine Erseng
En lui disant, voilà, c'est toi qui sélectionne une question par lettre de l'alphabet
Tu me les poses dans une vidéo, et moi j'y réponds.
Je n'ai pas encore vu les vidéos, je ne sais pas quelles sont les questions qu'elle va me poser
Merci à vous tous d'avoir participé, on en a reçu 5 000 en 24 heures.
Elle a eu un petit peu de travail...
C'est parti !
Alors évidemment, bonjour à tous, voilà j'aimerai savoir comment fais tu pour lier tes deux travails
à savoir youtube et les spectacles, et comment arrives-tu à trouver encore du temps libre ?
Si toutes les questions sont aussi longues, on va galérer.
Euh... Je n'ai plus de temps libre, et je n'ai plus de sommeil. Voilà, Next !
Bannies- tu des personnes de l'espace commentaires ?
Car sous chaque vidéos ils t'insultent etc.
Si oui, l'as tu déjà fait ?
Ah oui donc on est aussi sur les questions qui fachent
Alors, je m'étais à la base dit que jamais je ne bannirai quelqu'un de l'espace commentaires
et ça m'est arrivé pour deux personnes cet été
c'est pas tant qu'ils étaient insultants envers moi, mais envers vous, les abonnés qui commentez.
Et autant des insultes envers moi ça ne me fait rien, autant il est hors de question que des personnes insultent gratuitement les gens qui commentent,
ou aussi les gens qui passent dans mes vidéos.
Chocolatine ou pain au chocolat ?
Chocolatine ! La Rochelle représente !
De quoi le monde est-il fait ?
Bah enfin tout le monde le sait... Le monde est composé de pouces en l'air!
Donc forcément si vous ne likez pas la vidéo, ça peut créer un trou noir.
Non c'est sérieux ! C'est pour ça que tous les youtubeurs vous le rappellent !
Est ce que comme Doc Seven et les papillons, Max Bird avec les oiseaux,
tu as d'autres passions que le mentalisme et les thèmes de tes vidéos ?
Malheureusement, j'ai plein de passions, mais je ne suis pas bon sur les rimes en "on" ... NEXT !
Feras-tu des lives ?
Je kiffes tellement ce qu'ils ont fait pour les questions, c'est trop bien ! C'est Barange qui est avec elle, que vous avez déjà vu sur la chaîne.
Alors oui, j'ai un début de projet de lives. Je vous en avais parlé dans la vidéo des 100 000 abonnés. Que du coup je vous invites à regarder.
Gagnais-tu ta vie seulement avec les revenus de ton spectacle avant Youtube ?
Elle est marrante cette question car on me la pose souvent
En fait, faire des spectacles c'est mon métier depuis des années
Et oui, c'est un métier, c'est ça qui me faisait vivre. C'est ça qui me fait vivre d'ailleurs encore aujourd'hui.
Youtube ne me permets pas du tout de gagner ma vie pleinement.
NEXT !
Habitues-tu à te lever tôt le matin ? Même si c'est pas français ça ne fait rien ...
Là on sent que ça lui à fait mal à Carine de dire une phrase qui n'était pas bien française
comme je lui avais dit, quoiqu'il arrive il faut que tu respectes absolument les questions comme elles sont écrites, elle l'a fait.
Mais c'était douloureux.
Surement assez douloureux que de devoir se lever assez tôt le matin
C'est pas le fait de se lever tôt d'ailleurs, ça c'est pas un problème,
C'est le fait de continuer à se coucher tard mais de se lever tôt ... D'un coup il y a comme un problème.
Mais je me suis raté quand même deux fois cette année.
Iras-tu à la VCP, Vidéo City Paris ?
Ca devait être fin 2016, et du coup c'est en 2017
et j'ai déjà un truc de prévu sur l'un des deux jours, mais j'irai comme vous en fait, j'irai me promener là bas à la VCP
mais je n'ai pas du tout reçu de carton d'invitation.
Joues-tu de la cornemuse ?
C'est trop intime comme question, NEXT !
Kronenbourg ou Heineken ?
Non mais ça c'est pareil, je ne vais pas répondre à ça. Ca ne regarde que moi le fait que j'aime et j'adore la Heineken.
Jamais j'y répondrais !
Les vidéos que tu as tournées en avance mais que tu n'as pas upload, tu vas les mettre en cours de fin d'année ou l'année prochaine ?
Je pense par exemple aux vidéos de comment résoudre un Rubiks cube, que tu as dis dans une de tes anciennes vidéos.
Et c'est là où je me dis, en fait tout le travail que j'ai fait cette année... Il y a peut être trop de vidéos, j'en sais rien.
Ça arrive régulièrement qu'on me pose une question sur une vidéo qui a été faite dans la semaine
ou des gens qui participent à un concours qui est fini depuis des mois.
Les vidéos pour le Rubiks cube je les ai mises au mois de juillet
On est au mois de novembre !
Et c'est terrible car je fais des playlists etc. J'organise au mieux la chaîne pour que ce soit clair et lisible, mais pas tellement en fait.
Après il y a un truc qui marche, ça aurait été de taper Fabien Olicard Rubiks cube pour voir si elles étaient sorties ou pas.
Mentaliseras-tu quelqu'un de célèbre ou peut être que tu l'as déjà fait?
Dans ce cas peux-tu nous dire si tu as réussi, et qui c'était ?
On est complètement dans la suite de la réponse de la vidéo d'avant.
C'est à dire qu'en 327 vidéos, il y a des gens qui sont plutôt connus parfois sur la chaîne,
que ce soit des youtubeurs, des artistes ou des choses comme ça.
Après connus, ça dépend de qui tu connais ou pas...
J'ai fait des vidéos avec Artus, avec Pierre Croce, avec Doc Seven, et je peux faire mieux que te dire si j'ai réussi ou pas
il suffit de regarder la playlist "Tours de mentalisme"
Vraiment ma chaîne n'est pas claire apparemment.
Nommes les écoles que tu as fréquentées.
Je n'ai même plus envie de répondre aux questions, j'ai juste envie de regarder leurs vidéos.
Pour les écoles, j'étais à l'école maternelle de Marsilly, l'école primaire de Marsilly,
le collège Jean Guiton à Lagord, et après je suis allé au lycée Léonce Vieljeux, à La Rochelle
et pour après tout ça, il y a un vidéo qui est prévue la dessus donc je ne vous en parle pas !
Où souhaiterais-tu le plus faire un spectacle, et pourquoi? Carine Erseng, en direct de l'Olympia.
Alors je ne sais pas tellement car j'ai eu la chance de beaucoup voyager
avec mon spectacle, donc je l'ai joué un petit peu partout dans le monde.
Pas forcément celui ci exactement, mais j'ai joué dans pas mal d'endroits.
Et avec celui ci j'ai quand même foulé des grandes scènes
J'ai joué à l'Olympia pour "le Point Virgule fait l'Olympia", je suis allé jouer au festival de Québec
J'ai fait les premières parties en Zenith de Jeff Panacloc
J'ai fait un plateau à Bobino, j'ai joué mon spectacle au Point Virgule, au Grand Point Virgule.
J'ai fait pas mal de trucs super cools que je rêvais de faire.
Je pense surement que c'est assez classique, mais le truc que je n'ai pas fait c'est de jouer mon spectacle entier à l'Olympia
Je ne l'ai pas fait en entier là bas.
Donc ce serai ça sûrement s'il y avait un rêve.
Penses-tu qu'un jour tu vas y arriver au million d'abonnés?
Aucune idée, je ne pensais même pas avoir 100 000 personnes qui suivent la chaîne cette année
et on est au double quasiment
Alors je ne sais pas si j'attendrais le million d'abonnés un jour, d'ailleurs on parle en chiffres comme ça
mais moi je préfère parler en personnes, aux un million de personnes qui regardent les vidéos et qui suivent la chaîne
Mais si ça doit arriver un jour je ne suis qu'à 20% de ça en fait
Et 20% c'est pas grand chose
Donc aucune idée, sincèrement aucune idée, mais déjà j'ai prévu un gros truc si un jour on atteint les 500 000 abonnés
Ce qui est déjà énorme!
et je vous en parlait également dans la vidéo des 100 000 abonnés
Quel superpouvoir aimerais-tu bien avoir si tu pouvais choisir d'en avoir un ?
Arrêter le temps !
Pouvoir stopper le temps en claquant des doigts et le faire repartir en reclaquant des doigts.
Et d'après vous quelle est la première chose que je ferai en stoppant le temps comme ça à loisir ?
Je dormirai ! Vraiment je crois que j'en profiterai pour éliminer le sommeil de ma vie réelle
Et je dormirai en pause, en faisant une pause dans le temps
et je lirai des livres, aussi, j'en profiterai pour lire des livres comme ça.
Ca serai tellement bien !
Restera-t-il du couscous après le diner?
Je te soupçonne Carine d'avoir sélectionné cette question uniquement pour faire ce trip sur M et mettre tes cheveux comme ça
Et non il ne restera pas de couscous parce que je mangerai tout
NEXT !
Sachant que tu as 146 000 abonnés, que comptes-tu faire pour le million, les 500 000 ?
Ah du coup j'ai déjà répondu à cette question
Veuillez vous référer à la lettre P
Ta calvitie a commencé à quel âge ?
Mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce bazar ? Cette question est deux fois gênante !
Premièrement elle est gênante car à cause de Carine Erseng, on va tous avoir cette musique là dans la tête
C'est sur ! D'ici une heure ou deux vous allez fredonner *air de chanson*
et vous allez vous dire, "super c'est grâce à l'Alfa-Q
Et la deuxième chose qui est gênante c'est que je n'ai pas de calvitie
Non mais une calvitie c'est ici. Je n'ai pas de calvitie moi mon gars !
Je pense que tu voulais parler de ce large front
un petit peu comme dans Minus et Cortex
Et bien ce n'est pas que j'ai un large front, c'est que mes cheveux ont du mal à descendre sur le front
et ça a toujours été comme ça
et je te déteste
Une personnalité dont tu es fan ?
Je suis ultra fan d'Alexandre Astier
De tout ce qu'il fait et aussi de la personne en elle même
Voudriez-vous bien poser cette question dans votre vidéo FAQ s'il vous plaît ?
Non, hors de question ! NEXT !
Mais ? Du coup il y a pas ... ?
Waouh, quel est on secret pour toujours avoir le sourire?
Et bien j'ai failli le perdre car je viens d'avoir un soucis de caméra, mais c'est bon, elle est repartie !
Alors je ne sais pas si j'ai toujours le sourire par contre je suis toujours content de faire ce que je fais
et dans la vie j'ai toujours fait ce que j'aimais faire
c'est ma seule priorité
et quand tu fais toujours ce que tu aimes, que ça marche ou pas, tu es quand même content de l'avoir fait et du résultat.
Le succès d'un projet, et la réussite de faire ce que tu aimes faire tout les jours, sont deux choses différentes
et ça me fout la patate !
X+2+4/3=5 donc X=combien?
Alors j'essaye de ne pas tricher, c'était X+2+4
donc X+6/3=5
donc x+6=15
donc X=15-6
donc X=9
Si je ne me suis pas trompé dans l'énoncé
Et si je me suis planté je pense que je vais en entendre parler dans les commentaires
Y a-t-il des projets en cours dont tu peux nous parler ?
Oui il y a des projets en cours mais je vais pas trop vous en parler
principalement car j'aime bien parler des choses quand elles sont sures
et puis aussi parce que j'aimerai bien vous faire des surprises
mais je vous en parlerai vite.
Zut, lendemain de soirée
j'ai oublié le nom de la fille qui est
dans mon lit ce matin
comment je fais pour le retrouver ?
je peux lui poser des questions, je peux lui poser des questions ?
Bah oui !
Tu marques son numéro de téléphone, tu lui demandes
et puis après tu lui demandes de t'épeler son prénom
et puis elle va te l'épeler
et si elle dit, bin Virginie ça s'écrit Virginie
tu lui dis et bien non, figures toi que j'ai rencontré un jour une Virginy avec un Y, et je ne veux pas véxer maintenant
et tu bidouilles un petit peu.
Facile !
Ainsi s'achève l'Alfa-Q
C'est un concept  ! On va pas se mentir l'Alfa-Q c'est quand même un concept
26 questions. Je pense que cette vidéo doit être très très longue
Et j'en suis très content, pourquoi ?
Parce que Carine m'a chanté toutes les questions. Merci Carine !
(Carine) Avec un immense plaisir !
Alors cette fille là, c'est ma rock star
En fait j'ai un couple de rock stars à moi, rien qu'à moi
C'est Carine et Victor Barange que vous avez déjà vu plein de fois sur la chaîne
Là vous vous dites, oui, Carine j'aime trop ce qu'elle fait, j'aime trop sa voix
et où est ce que je peux l'entendre chanter ?
C'est une bonne question !
Et bien sur Youtube mon pote !
Et aussi en vrai.
Sur Youtube je vous met le lien dans la description, tu as une chaîne Youtube
qui s'appelle ...
(Carine) Tu iras voir comment elle s'appelle !
C'est du mentalisme attend, ne bouges pas
qui s'appelle Carine Erseng !
C'est ça ou pas ?
(Victor) C'est ça, je pense que c'est ça
(Carine) Oui c'est ça, Carine Erseng, on a pas pu faire plus compliqué
Comme vous êtes mentaliste vous sentez que c'est ... très actif cette chaîne Youtube
Mais je pense que si vous arrivez comme ça sur sa chaîne, ça va la motiver à sortir encore plus de choses
Et moi je serai le 22 décembre au bateau Le Nez Rouge
Je sais que ce n'est pas la date que je vous ai annoncé du tout
mais c'est Carine Erseng qui joue là bas
et moi je vais venir te voir.
J'ai déjà ma place.
Et vous aussi peut être, si ça vous tente, si vous êtes sur Paris
venez, c'est une seule date, et c'est le 22 décembre
et en plus on se croisera là bas et on applaudira tous Carine ensemble.
(Carine) A 21h !
(Fabien) Et on fera ...
(Carine) Au bassin de la Villette
*Fabien chante*. C'est ça hein ?
*Carine chante*
*Tous chantent*
Si vous ne connaissez pas ça c'est que vous ne connaissez pas les chansons de Carine Erseng
et vous allez kiffer ça ! Venez le 22 décembre, c'est super cool !
Et là attention je fais ça et il y a un bouton pour s'abonner à la chaîne de Carine
et un bouton pour s'abonner à la chaîne de Victor
Merci à vous d'avoir regardé la vidéo et n'oubliez pas de laisser un pouce en l'air
et de vous abonner en cliquant ici, par exemple, peut être
et surtout à eux deux.
C'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an, du 1er janvier au 31 décembre
CIAO !